all right what's up mkbhd here and today
was google's i o their annual developer
conference and usually we don't see a
ton of hardware at events like this but
this one for whatever reason we got a
ton of hardware or at least hardware
announcements so there's kind of three
levels of announcements going on here so
first of all there's the
right around the corner coming up next
stuff that's two things and they're
going to be going on sale in the next
month or so
then there's the
later this year section so we did get a
bit of a sneak preview at some more fall
hardware some stuff that we're actually
going to get fully unveiled later this
year
and then there's the on the horizon
section which is they went ahead and
pre-announced
a piece of 2023 hardware
for some reason but we'll get to that
but first of all in the next up section
pixel 6a and pixel buds pro these are
both things that we kind of knew were
coming but now we're finally getting all
the details of these announcements so
for the pixel 6a it is essentially a
slightly smaller slightly bumped down
pixel six and it will retail for 449. so
honestly from what we can tell here the
6a will be very similar to the pixel 6.
you can see the design same camera bar
same glass same software with all the
material you and live captions and
speech recognition and camera features
and it's powered by the same exact
tensor chip from the flagship pixel six
and six pro but you know those phones
are going on past six months old now so
you can imagine the price of
manufacturing some of those parts is
starting to go down but the real main
difference between the pixel 6a
and the pixel 6 which is 599 is the
display and cameras which is really
interesting so for the display it is
smaller a little bit the more premium
pixels are both pretty big this will
have a 6.1 inch 1080p
60 hertz g-o-led display which is still
big but it's now the smallest pixel so
then cameras are the other interesting
thing so now google telling us that
cameras are one of the areas where they
saved cost from the pixel 6 means that
yeah okay this a is going to have
cheaper cameras than the pixel 6 which
worried me at first so it is still a
standard and an ultra wide and you can
kind of see a slightly new visual design
in the camera bar which i'll touch on
more in a second but on the spec sheet
it actually tells us it is the sony imx
363 that's the sensor for the main
camera which is actually the same 12
megapixel sensor that we've seen in some
of those older pixels pixel 4 pixel 3
pixel 2 this is a tried and true
older sensor so cheaper yes
but also probably not bad but other
things like materials and battery appear
to be about the same although do
definitely have to test that stuff i i
would suggest getting subscribed to see
that review video when it comes out here
battery could be an interesting one
because this is the smallest lowest
refresh rate display in any pixel but it
still has the same
tensor chip so we'll see how that gets
handled could be amazing but the other
specs i can confirm are six gigs of ram
and 128 gigs of storage ip67 water
resistance it does have an in display
fingerprint reader there's a 4400
milliamp hour battery with 18 watt
charging but there is no mention of
wireless charging and then sub 6 5g and
millimeter wave 5g with specific models
and five years of android security
updates so that's the pixel 6a and
that's the new budget smartphone but
it's launching alongside a new high-end
set of earbuds from google
pixel buds pro so if we have pixel buds
a series i looked on google store that's
actually the only one they're selling
right now so the a series for 100 bucks
is like regular airpods basically and
then pixel buds pro for 200 bucks would
be sort of equivalent to airpods pro so
this is a 199 dollar noise canceling
pair of wireless earbuds they do have a
transparency mode they'll have
multi-device connectivity compatible
with android ios and computers google
assistants built-in they have ipx4 sweat
resistance and overall the design i'm
going to say it looks pretty tame you
know you can see the mics each earbud
has three microphones you got the
silicon tips in front of an 11
millimeter driver
and the case looks basically the same as
the original pixel buds with the black
and white design and the magnet and
wireless charging the quoted battery
life is 11 hours of listening or seven
hours with active noise cancellation
turned on
basically i feel like the
differentiating factor with these
especially when we get them and listen
to how they sound is gonna come from the
six core audio chip on board which also
apparently will have a lot to do with
the noise cancellation the transparency
mode and just overall the way they sound
now i've been waiting a long time for a
pair of earbuds with noise cancellation
and a transparency mode that rivals
airpods airpods still to this day have
far and away the best transparency mode
i've ever heard in any pair of
headphones so i'm looking forward to
maybe pixel buds stepping their game up
in that dimension it's just one part of
headphones um but yeah the competition
has a lot of other things going for them
so we'll see how the pixel buds stack up
but yeah that's what's up next that's
the stuff that'll be on sale this summer
but then google went ahead and gave us a
little bit of a preview of some stuff
that's coming up this fall including a
full design reveal of the pixel 7 and 7
pro and
a new pixel watch
finally so this is our limited first
look at the pixel 7 and 7 pro so the
details of course are way more confined
with this stuff but you can see the new
colors here and you can also see a bit
more of that camera design and super
bold big camera circles and the camera
bar and an extra detail is we also know
that that glass is soft touch which i am
very excited about so they've sort of
gone back and forth on soft touch but if
you remember the pixel threes with the
soft touch glass i remember i really
liked that back of a phone finish if
it's anything like that
i'm very excited about it and seeing as
there is a black 7 pro at the bottom i'm
thinking that's probably going to end up
being the one i prefer although matt
white typically does a great job hiding
fingerprints so we'll see this phone
will have the next generation tensor
chip and it will launch with android 13
but that's pretty much all we know at
this point so yeah new phone coming out
this fall pixel 7 and 7 pro new chip new
colors new matte finish and then
yeah i guess we can also technically see
it still has a port at the bottom and it
definitely has speakers all the classic
stuff some new colors i'm not sure how i
feel about this gray with the green
undertone but it does contrast well with
the gold but probably the more
interesting preview we got is the one of
the new pixel
watch
they're finally doing it this fall we're
going to have i mean theoretically maybe
a competitor to the apple watch but sort
of in the android world i've been
waiting for this for a long time
it's a sort of a result of their
collaboration or i guess purchase of
fitbit and this is it this is the pixel
watch
so okay it's a circular stainless steel
design and it is a very simple
silhouette as you can see not a whole
lot to set it apart on the outside but i
do like that it is simple and it has
what they're calling a tactile crown for
input though it's also a touch screen
and it has interchangeable bands and it
runs wear os
this is the pixel watch that we've been
i mean hearing so much about for so long
and waiting for
it's clearly got some solid bezels all
the way around i mean that's the first
thing i notice when the screen is on
and i guess i'm judging just by
eyeballing these lifestyle photos but it
looks like it's about the same size as
the smaller apple watch i'm thinking
maybe around 40 millimeters
there isn't any mention of two different
sizes like a small and a large i think
it would make sense but they didn't say
but basically that's all we really know
know about the new pixel watch again
this is something that we're gonna get
way more details on when it actually
does get fully unveiled in october
whenever their event is but there are a
bunch of things that i'm also hoping for
like i'm hoping it has a bright
efficient crispy oled display you know
this ui they're showing has a lot of
black and the black bezel clearly goes
all the way around so i'm hoping that
it's an oled so it can sort of
seamlessly blend into the bezel instead
of being really obvious and ugly like a
cheaper lcd
i'm also of course hoping for good
battery life at least a full day and if
it's going to be a premium price i'm
also hoping it has things like good
haptics and good performance these
animations of the ui showing smart home
controls and checking notifications like
it's cool but again i definitely want to
play with it myself one thing to note
though is this is basically going to act
like a fitbit like it seems like most of
the the fitness tracking and sleep
tracking and stuff like that you need
the fitbit app to work for so
it's going to act just like a fitbit in
that way and then wear os is going to
work the way you typically expect it to
paired with an android phone and then
they've said there will be a cellular
option so the watch can work without the
phone and it'll do activity and sleep
tracking and stuff like that through
fitbit and also it appears this will
just be working specifically with
android phones probably best with the
pixel but with android phones and not
the iphone because in classic apple
fashion lots of the stuff that the apple
watch can do
no other smartwatch has access to so
this this is very much an android
smartwatch so yeah stay tuned for more
details on that later but yeah then last
but not least
this was the announcement we got
basically zero information on but google
did officially say that they're going to
be dropping a pixel
tablet
in 2023
that's what they've told us that's kind
of all we know like we don't know any of
the specs we don't know what time of
year it'll come out we don't know what
it'll even really be called technically
we do know it will be on the larger side
and on the premium side so i'm thinking
like ipad air to ipad pro type price
range and equivalent but
it feels like they're not really
committing to anything else yet as far
as a tablet goes i guess visually
basically we just have this shot of the
pixel portfolio where we can see that
there is a tablet and it'll definitely
have a camera
and speakers
and presumably a screen on the other
side but yeah that's it it's really
interesting that they're deciding to
show off some of this stuff so early it
kind of reminds me on one hand of sony
who will announce a phone early in the
year and then six months later it'll
finally come out and all the hype is
gone and everybody forgot about it but
on the other hand this is google we're
talking about and they've always been
leaking things constantly i mean they
try to get ahead of the leaks this feels
like them just going hey you know what
instead of the phone leaking for the
next six months we'll just tell people
about it and take advantage of that
because
otherwise you just lose the hype and
your own messaging so yeah let me know
what you think is the most exciting or
what you're looking forward to the most
of this new google stuff i'm definitely
interested in in the watch actually i
want to see what that's like on the
wrist and to actually use but let me
know in the comments section below we'll
talk about it but yeah that's been it
thanks for watching also random shout
out but the ipod
was officially discontinued this week
probably one of the products everyone
watching this video has at some point
owned some version of
so rip press f and in the chat to pay
respects all right catch you guys the
next one peace